[Musique]
c'est toujours
reconverti en vaccinodromes accueille
ses premiers patients objectif 10 mille
injection par semaine et pour augmenter
la cadence même l'armée mobilisée dès
aujourd'hui sept hôpitaux militaires
ouvrent des centres de vaccination dans
plusieurs régions de france peut être
vaccinés et prescripteurs d'opinion
par exemple vous monsieur bourdin par
exemple j'ai reçu première dose à ben
voilà mais non mais typiquement des
artistes des sportifs des personnalités
les vaccinés pour dire ça n'est pas
dangereux
allez-y c'est le plus gros poisson la
ruse de l'histoire de ces dix ou quinze
vingt dernières années
et j'avoue que franchement si les gens
n'ont pas un peu d'humour
eh bien ils n'ont rien compris en tout
cas c'était un énorme poisson d'avril
un poisson d'avril qui a marché je ne
pensais pas qu'ils marcheraient à ce
point là samedi lors d'une messe à
l'église saint-eugène sainte cécile à
paris
des dizaines de fidèles serrés les uns à
côté des autres
les prêtres eux officient sans masque
l'hostis mêmes données directement par
le prêtre à chaque personne j'ai pas vu
ces images mais évidemment accès aux
lieux de culte reste autorisée il l'est
avec des jauges il est avec un certain
nombre de mesures barrières qui sont à
demander et donc dès lors qu'on ne les
respecte pas on prend un risque pour
soif le monde doit être responsable
on est responsable on est responsable
pour soi et aux responsables et on est
responsable pour les autres y compris et
surtout dans un lieu d'église
j'ai pas vu ces images pour être honnête
vous me l'apprenez mais c'est évidemment
inadmissible
j'ai découvert hier soir cette vidéo
j'étais stupéfait par ce que ce qu'on y
voit ne correspond pas du tout aux
consignes que nous avons donné à toutes
les paroisses de paris déjà depuis
depuis longtemps et spécialement cette
fête de pâques et qui je dois dire ont
été très largement respectés
j'ai constaté ce matin que le diocèse de
paris avait condamné ceux qui
organisaient des des rassemblements
culturels en dehors du protocole je
remercie le diocèse de paris à chaque
fonction donc le doigt était nouveau
l'eau était désinfecter comment on pas
lorsqu on baptise voilà puis la réaction
de florian philippot qui lui a été
horrifiée par le fait que quelqu'un ait
signalé ces pratiques recul
ils croient posséder la chaîne russe en
plein duplex hier le lol voilà elle
faisait tranquillement la météo
son micro la vraie dans la tête
présentait certains mythes en plateau
érectile ce 13e premiers pas de temps
pour ça notre équipe m'a prévenu que
quelqu'un était en train de détériorer
l'oeuvre alors que je suis venu tout de
suite on a appelé la police qui a
récupéré la peinture et le pinceau comme
pièces à conviction
on a tout de suite garder les bandes des
caméras de surveillance où on les voit
peindre sur la toile avant de partir ils
nous ont dit qu'ils pensaient que
c'était autorisé que c'était une oeuvre
participative dans le figaro michel
houellebecq évoque les soins palliatifs
la morphine et l'hypnose capable de
soulager les malades
il fustige des sondages qui selon lui
sont tronqués font croire que tous les
français approuvent l'euthanasie et il
termine par cette formule lorsqu'un pays
une société une civilisation en vient à
légaliser l'euthanasie
il perd à mes yeux tout droit au respect
ils vont s'emparer d'une bombe de
peinture et d'un pinceau et qui vont y
mettre leur leur signature voilà on les
voit d'impôt d'un peu plus près sauf que
voilà les bombes de peinture que vous
voyez devant l'oeuvre
elle faisait en fait partie de
l'installation c'était pas du tout du
libre-service ici